hey guys Manna Dey back in Roseanne's
kitchen table and I've noticed a couple
times we've been doing a lot of shows
together and they're been twice in the
last month or two where you've actually
changed my mind on issues in the middle
of a show and then once you said that
that's the type of thing that actually
never happened never never happens on
cable TV where someone actually sort of
changes their opinion or here's actually
here's something right because that's
what nobody does on cable nobody's
hearing their just talk talk talk has
ever been a moment on cable news where
the one person said to another day
that's interesting I never thought about
it that way that's loot that those words
have never spoken yet able as you'd
think with maybe a billion hours of
arguments about theoretically about
ideas our previous segment established i
think that they don't talk about ideas
but talking about issues right at some
point you think oh yeah you know cuz all
the time happens to me yeah i'll come in
and i'll have an opinion Jake and I used
to argue a lot and more often than not I
felt like he and I think yeah i guess
that is right ortel turner yet in
writing i read that i didn't know that
you know right nobody everybody knows
everything boy so we're pretty fantastic
that we are willing to accept that we
don't know everything so dumb that's a
gift right um so I think that one of the
things that you that we were debating
about that you kind of change what I was
thinking was during that whole
immigration thing and I was saying how
the executive actions that this isn't
sort of how it's supposed to work and
you kind of laid out why they've all
done this and I knew that that actually
Obama hasn't done that many executive
actions relative to other president um
and I the the part that I was coming at
it from was that I want the system to
work the way it's supposed to work I
still have this like belief that the
system should actually work with
branches of government doing what
there's was to be doing and you kind of
had a little more of I guess a realistic
or realists view on that wha so my
question is how [ __ ] broke is the
system what the hell can we do it's
really broken it's it's very broken
because one side doesn't really want to
participate in it I mean and and whether
it's because they hated this particular
president they did and there's
definitely some stranger racism that
existed here but keep in mind they
impeached the last democratic president
right for a job doesn't that seem right
to the retros
back now they made the guy who got a
[ __ ] from an intern in the Oval
Office the most popular president of our
time right yeah um they just left him
alone I think it goes out you know with
a low approval rating and not able to
get things done but they couldn't resist
themselves you make a sexy up there
somehow with he goes out with a low
there is something right low
testosterone yes um so uh I don't it is
incredibly broken but that said these
guys are into the the the right is not
interested a big part of the right is
interested governing at all you know
it's a strange world where we now look
to the guy who was reelected a speaker
today John Boehner and think he's that's
a guy we can deal with it right but as
true at least John Boehner likes
politics likes the process of government
I like the process of government so just
to put a stamp on your immigration point
like I like that were like hey man I
gotta get some done and you guys are
gonna do anything so I McGovern reg of
ER I like governing and it's ugly and so
yeah it's not exactly how we drew it up
but it's almost it's almost never been
how we drew it up television has helped
advance nothing I can area ideas and I
although I couldn't live without you're
right um yeah I guess it's a the ID so
it's the idea thing they were talking
about before we don't have the the
debate about ideas but also there's
something about that the system just
can't move that much right like
philosophically the system can only move
a little bit one way or the other
ultimately right if Jake we're sitting
here or any one of a number of people
who believe that the only the biggest
problem by far the elephant in the room
that the the herd in the room where the
elephant in the room is his money in
politics and that money which was always
important you always raise money but but
freshman congressman now who are have
been have been scolded by leader by
members of leadership of their own party
when they're seen at lunch having lunch
being like hey man take a sandwich back
to your office and get on the phone
you're raising money seventy percent of
the time that's what you do I am certain
that congressman the nineteen fifties
sixties and seventies and prior to that
had to raise money no way
to raise money like this there wasn't
this much money at stake k street it
wasn't a foregone conclusion you know
guys would leave Congress they'd lose
and they go home they go back to Kansas
they go back to Milwaukee they go back
to Seattle well wait are you saying that
they didn't all immediately get 3
million dollar year jobs on Wall Street
like Eric and I didn't just that wasn't
always that were all his non wall street
with no experience whatsoever right but
he has the context is power and so so I
suppose that I I now you know I believe
that to be right that though that we get
money out of politics in whatever way we
can that that is a big step toward
rectifying the situation and and and the
wolfpack the young turks pack has been
incredibly successful there three states
now I imagine once they hit 9 10 12
states that that those money entities
are going to be like now we need now we
need to pay attention well we need to
start because the love the the
legislators who voted for it in those
states they didn't receive huge pressure
from the coax of the world not to that
money will come and that pressure will
be exerted at the state level right so
that's the interesting part so of course
we need money out of politics so there
are things that are happening not just
what back but there's a bunch of are
happening uh to either get a
constitutional convention or uh whatever
it is to change some of the laws uh but
the real way to do is change gas station
right so so to your point though now
it's a three-state so let's say gets to
nine then the the system that's what I'm
saying that then the system will be
invested in protecting the system uh and
I sort of fear what the what they do
when ultimately if there's a real
groundswell of support ill it'll happen
but it is really hard to when the you
know as the we saw the Koch brothers
spend money like on the Kansas uh Kansas
State House races that nobody cared
about and that we're a typical race
might have twenty or thirty thousand
dollars spent all summer spending
hundreds thousand dollars on what those
candidates all one yeah right because
you can if you can if you have people
who can offensive effectively deliver a
message and we've learned that the right
can effectively deliver a message it's
not a message that's good for the
country or good for the people who are
literally supporting it but they can do
it effectively if you have three hundred
thousand dollars the other guy has a
dollar eighty there's a really good
chance the guy with three hours
going to win on that note can we change
the system can we get money out of
politics I have no idea but I kind of
hope so let us know in the comments
right down below